S
SITUATION TO PUT THEMSELVES IN.
JONATHAN TURLEY, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
NOW TO ANOTHER LINE FROM THE
LEGAL TEAM FILING SURROUNDING
THE SPECIAL MASTER "LEFT
UNCHECKED TO THE DOJ WILL
IMPUGN, LEAK, AND PUBLICIZE
SELECTIVE ASPECTS OF THEIR
INVESTIGATION WITH NO RECOURSE
BUT TO SOMEHOW TRUST THE
SELF-RESTRAINT OF CURRENTLY
UNCHECKED INVESTIGATORS" HERE IS
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ATTORNEY AS
WELL AS FOX NEWS LEGAL ANALYST
GREGG JARRETT AND PAM BONDI.
GOOD TO SEE YOU ALL.
LET'S GET YOUR TAKE FIRST.
>> I THINK THAT THEY WERE ASTUTE
IN THEIR FILING TODAY.
AND PART OF THE LEGAL TEAM THAT
BROUGHT THIS UP.
I THINK THAT THEY DID PUT THIS
PICTURE AS MR. TURLEY MENTIONED
WAS MORE FOR THE PUBLIC EYE.
AND THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT WE ARE
NOT SUPPOSED TO DO.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE PREPARATION.
IT'S ABOUT THE JUSTICE.
AND IT'S NOT WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
OUT OF THIS ADMINISTRATION.
WE ARE SEEING A LOT OF PUBLIC
PLAY AND I HOPE THAT WE CAN GET
THE SPECIAL MASTER PUT IN PLACE
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE SOME
IMPARTIAL MEDIATORS TO LOOK AT
EVERYTHING AND GET THE DOCUMENTS
THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO BE WITH THE
PRESIDENT BACK AND LOOK AT
EVERYTHING.
IN A PERFECT EYE.
THE PRESIDENTIAL ACT PROTECTED
HIM AND ALLOWED HIM TO
DECLASSIFY MATERIALS, NOBODY
TALKS ABOUT THAT.
INSTEAD THEY LOOK AT THE
STATUTES THEY BROUGHT.
I THINK THAT OUR PAPERS ARE GOOD
AND LOOKING FORWARD TO WHAT TO
THE JUDGE HAS TO SAY TOMORROW.
>> Sean: I WOULD LIKE YOUR
TAKE AS OPPOSED TO THE
DECLASSIFIED RANGE OF THIS.
IS THIS STILL AN ISSUE IN
QUESTION?
BECAUSE I SEE PEOPLE ON THE LEFT
JUST AUTOMATICALLY DISMISS IT.
THAT IS NOT DECLASSIFIED, HOW
WOULD THEY KNOW?
>> THEY WOULD NOT KNOW, SEAN,
BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD KNOW.
HIS LEGAL TEAM WHEN NOW, THAT
COUNSEL'S OFFICE WITH NO AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS SAID HE HAS
DECLASSIFIED THESE MATERIALS.
HE WAS THE PRESIDENT IN THE
UNITED STATES AND HAS THE RIGHT
TO DO SO.
AND IT WILL BE WHO WILL POLICE
THE POLICE?
THEY DON'T WANT TO SPECIAL
MASTER.
AS A PROSECUTOR IF SOMEONE WAS
CHALLENGING MY ETHICS AND THE
COURT OF LAW AND SAYING LET'S
BRING IN AN INDEPENDENT PERSON
TO LOOK AT THIS, I WOULD SAY,
GLADLY.
PLEASE COME IN AND LOOK AT THE
EVIDENCE, LOOK AT WHAT WE HAVE.
IF THEY HAVE NOTHING TO HIDE,
THEY SHOULD WELCOME A SPECIAL
MASTER INSTEAD OF FIGHTING
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN HIS LEGAL
TEAM AT EVERY SINGLE TURN.
>> Sean: FIRST IT WAS THE PASS
BOARDS, NOW IS ATTORNEY-CLIENT
PRIVILEGE INFORMATION THAT THEY
TOOK OUT OF MAR-A-LAGO, I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT HAS BEEN RETURNED
YET.
NOW IT IS ABOUT A TANK TEAM AS
YOU HAVE RIGHTLY POINTED OUT IN
YOUR COLUMNS AS PEOPLE
INVESTIGATING THEMSELVES, WHY
THE MYSTERIOUS RELUCTANCE,
RESISTANCE TOWARDS AN OBJECTIVE
SPECIAL MASTER AND HOW DO YOU
CITE SPECIAL SECURITY WHEN YOU
CAN HAVE SOMEBODY WITH A
SECURITY CLEARANCE BE THE
SPECIAL MASTER?
>> YEAH, LOOK, I READ THE COURT
FILING AND I HAVE TO SAY IT IS
ONE OF THE MOST FEEBLE AND
ANEMIC ARGUMENTS BY
MERRICK GARLAND THAT I THINK I
HAVE EVER READ IN A COURT
FILING.
NO LEGAL STANDING TO GO TO
COURT, HE CLAIMS.
MY GOODNESS, A FIRST-YEAR LAW
STUDENTS KNOWS THAT IF YOU ARE
THE TARGET OF A SEARCH AND
SEIZURE, YOU HAVE A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO GO TO
COURT AND ARGUE A VIOLATION OF
THE FOURTH AMENDMENT TO EITHER
SUPPRESS IT OR AT THE VERY LEAST
HAVE SPECIAL MASTER REVIEW AND
SEGREGATE THE MATERIAL.
THE OTHER PART OF WHAT WAS IN
THE COURT FILING WAS THIS CRAZY
NOTION OF OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
WHAT IS THAT?
YOU HAVE TO PROVE THAT A PERSON
ACTED CORRUPTLY AND WITH AN
IMPROPER PURPOSE.
AND THE SUPREME COURT HAS
NARROWED IT FURTHER AND YOU HAVE
TO ACT IN MORALLY WITH THE
DEPRAVED AND EVIL PURPOSE.
WHERE IS EVIDENCE OF THAT?
IF THE PRESIDENT TRULY THOUGHT
HE HAD THE RIGHT TO ACCESS AND
CUSTODY OF THESE PRESIDENTIAL
PAPERS, THERE IS NO CORRUPT
INTENSE, AND LOOK AT THE WARRANT
CITED BY MERRICK GARLAND, THEY
ALL REQUIRE NUMBINGLY TO
WILLFULLY BREAKING THE LAW.
AND IT IS WHERE I DECLASSIFIED
IT AND HAD A RIGHT INTO THE
RECORDS ACT TO HAVE ACCESS TO
IT, THEN THERE IS NO CRIMINAL
INTENT HERE.
ALL OF THAT IS NOT ADDRESSED BY
MERRICK GARLAND, INSTEAD THEY
THROW A PREJUDICIAL AND
GRATUITOUS PHOTOGRAPH AND THEY
ARE MEANT TO BE INCENDIARY AND
INFLAMMATORY, THEY SPOON-FED IT
TO THE MEDIA.
IT JUST SHOWS YOU HOW RUTHLESS
AND DEPRAVED MERRICK GARLAND AND
HIS TEAM OF PROSECUTORS ARE.
>> Sean: THAT'S EXACTLY WHERE
I'M HEADED, AND I WANT TO GET
YOUR TAKE ON THIS, OBVIOUSLY
DONE AND DESIGNED TO INFLUENCE
PUBLIC OPINION.
I THINK IT IS CLEAR AS HAVE ALL
OF THE OTHER LEAKS AS WELL.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE
MERRICK GARLAND THAT SAID OH, WE
WILL DO ALL OF OUR TALKING IN
COURT AND OUR FILINGS.
WHERE'S THAT GUY?
>> YEAH, NOWHERE.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED IS THEY HAVE
PUT THIS PICTURE OUT SO THAT YOU
WOULD ASSUME AND I AM SOMEBODY
WHO HAS BEEN IN THE PRESS AND
THEY LOVE TO TALK ABOUT THIS
SOMEBODY THAT HAS BEEN IN HIS
OFFICE, THIS IS NOT THE WAY THAT
IT LOOKS.
THEY GIVE YOU THIS APPEARANCE
THAT YOU WALK IN AND THERE ARE
THESE TOP-SECRET DOCUMENTS JUST
THROWN ABOUT, AND THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND, SOMETHING COULD BE
MARKED TOP-SECRET OR CLASSIFIED,
THE PROFESSIONAL ACTS HE WOULD
HAVE SAID IS DECLASSIFIED, DOES
NOT GET A NEW MARKING ALL THE
TIME AND IT LEFT THE OFFICE AS A
COMPLETE PUBLIC SPECTACLE.
AND I'M NOT GOING TO STAND BY IT
ANYMORE.
I'VE GOTTEN INTIMIDATED AND
PEOPLE HAVE TRIED TO INTIMIDATE
ME.
IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK.
YOU CAN'T GO LIKE THIS AND SAY,
LOOK.
>> Sean: DID THE FBI DO THAT
OR WAS THAT THE WAY IT LOOKED
BEFORE THEY WENT IN THERE?
>> YES, I AM SURE THAT YOU HAVE
SEEN THE PRESS TODAY, AND I DO
HAVE FIRSTHAND KNOWLEDGE, DOWN
THERE FREQUENTLY AND HAVE NEVER
SEEN THAT.
I HAVE NEVER EVER SEEN THAT.
THAT IS NOT THE WAY HIS OFFICE
WORKS.
ANYBODY WHO KNOWS
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S OFFICE, IT IS
JUST A JOKE.
THEY LITERALLY MUST HAVE GONE IN
AND TAKEN OUT DOCUMENTS THEY
WANTED OR COVER LETTERS AS IT IS
AND PUT IT ABOUT SO THAT THE
PUBLIC BELIEVES THIS IS
TOP-SECRET DOCUMENTS PUT ON HIS
FLOOR.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
I CAN TELL YOU PERSONALLY AND
>> Sean: SO WHAT WE ARE REALLY
LOOKING AT HERE IS THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, THE FBI
STAGING A PUBLIC OPINION.
WOULD THAT NOT ALL SO IF ALL THE
SPECULATION OF A POSSIBLE
INDICTMENT, WITH THAT ALSO PAINT
A JURY POOL?
AND TAINT PUBLIC OPINION AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP BY LAYING IT OUT
THAT WAY?
AND SHOWN INTO MERRICK GARLAND
SAY WE LAID IT OUT WAY?
WE TOOK THAT PICTURE AND RELEASE
THAT PICTURE AND HE SHOULD BE
ANSWERING QUESTIONS BEFORE
CONGRESS, WHY DIDN'T YOU --
KEEP TO YOUR WORD AND DO ALL OF
YOUR TALKING IN COURT?
AND WHERE ARE ALL OF THESE OTHER
LEAKS COMING FROM?
>> ABSOLUTELY, AND ALAYNA IS
RIGHT, HIS OFFICE IS NEAT AND
ORDERLY, I COULD NEVER SEE HIM
LEAVING ANYTHING CLASSIFIED
PREVIOUSLY CLASSIFIED AT ANY
TIME CLASSIFIED LAYING OUT IN
THE OPEN, THIS WAS MADE TO TAINT
A JURY AND TO TAINT THE
PERCEPTION OF HIM.
THEY HAVE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
SEVEN YEARS, THE MIDTERMS ARE
COMING UP AND THEN 2024.
THEY ARE AT THE END OF THEIR
ROPE AND DOING ANYTHING THEY CAN
TO HURT HIM.
ALL THE SEARCH WARRANTS, NOBODY
WOULD EVER PULL THINGS OUT AND
LAY THEM OUT THAT WAY.
IT MAKES NO SENSE OTHER THAN
THEY ARE STILL TRYING TO DESTROY
THE PRESIDENT.
AND IT'S NOT GOING TO WO